c'est une victoire qui fera date pour la
france insoumise la députée danielle
obono a gagné aujourd'hui son procès
contre le journal valeurs actuelles à
l'heure où les médias populiste sans
gagner en écoute la justice a fait le
choix de mettre quelques limites à la
caricature sur ce qui semble pour les
juges être un débordements racistes en
effet dans son édition de 2020 le
journal d'extrême droite valeurs
actuelles avait caricaturé la députée
france insoumise en esclave dans un
article de sept pages dont le titre
était au bono l'africaine le directeur
de la rédaction geoffrey lejeune est le
rédacteur de l'article laurent julien
ont été condamnés à une amende de 1500
euros chacun et à 5000 euros de dommages
et intérêts pour la victime néanmoins
pour certains cette condamnation va à
l'encontre de la liberté de caricaturer
d'expression pourtant vivement défendu
par la classe politique à leur valeur
actuelle condamné pour avoir caricaturé
une députée en esclaves comprenez vous
cette décision danièle obono était avec
nous ce soir pour commenter cette
condamnation danièle obono député la
france a soumises de paris est avec nous
merci et demi après la fin de son
parcours
là il l'homme et mon de personnes de la
france insoumis sur le plateau c'est
vraiment c'est vahid hormis signe
d'ailleurs actuellement la plupart à
kehl et alexis corbière il m'a vu à jean
luc mélenchon qui vient souvent de voir
mais vous n'étiez jamais venu donc merci
d'être là est ce que vous êtes heureuse
décision ce que c'est symboliquement
pour vous je sais que ce n'est pas une
question d'argent mais ce que
symboliquement c'est important pour vous
et vous êtes heureux aujourd'hui cc je
dirais que je suis reconnaissante et
fier je suis reconnaissante envers
toutes celles et ceux qui m'ont exprimé
leur soutien que ce soit les amis les
camarades la famille et surtout des
centaines des milliers d'inconnus en
france et au delà même à travers le
monde je suis reconnaissante envers les
avocats et avocates dont laquelle raguig
garrido mais si vous aviez souk celle
qui vous a représenté la france à
soullans donc avec raquel garrido a
gagné le procès aujourd'hui avec insert
étanche entre d'avocats et avocate qui
représente à elle et les associations
qui était partie civile
et je suis fier je suis fier aujourd'hui
d'être une femme noire et insoumise une
immigrée député de la république
française et qui a permis par cette
action de réaffirmer la devise qui est
la nôtre liberté égalité fraternité et
de faire respecter faire respecter par
la justice cette devise alors vous allez
voir déjà quelques minutes qui eric
zemmour qui est invité chez valeurs
actuelles qui a donné son avis sur cette
édition vous verrez ça dans un instant
et j'aimerais avoir votre avis ici
autour de la table est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette décision de justice
on va on va revoir je sais que c'est
compliqué pour vous danièle obono de
revoir ce que vous allez dire les
équipes vous avez dit que vous n'aviez
pas envie de revoir les caricatures
voilà qui avaient été faites ça vous a
quand vous avez vu ça j'ai l'impression
que ça nous a vraiment baissé c'est
vraiment ça j'ai l'impression que c'est
dur pour vous de les revoir c'est ce que
vous avez dit bah disons que je ne crois
pas que quiconque apprécie de vous
recevoir humiliés et traités de la sorte
donc effectivement c'est une violence
c'est c'est une à une injure à la fois
personnel et c'est ce que d'ailleurs la
cour a reconnu c'est pour ça que les
valeurs actuelles a été condamné parce
que c'est à ma personne à ce que je suis
et non pas à ce que je peux défendre et
qui fait partie du débat politique et
nous les insoumis insoumise on a su la
confrontation politique mais c'est ma
personne qui a été insulté humilié et
c'est aussi ma famille et c'est aussi
mon histoire et donc donc oui c'est
c'est une violence et est donc cette
violence devait être sanctionné alors je
vais prendre des personnes qui ne sont
pas d'accord avec cette décision parce
que voilà il ya d'abord ya beaucoup de
oui je voudrais d'abord démarré par deux
personnes qui sont pas d'accord de cette
décision du 6 avec benjamin et delphine
benjamin alors quoi en préambule je ne
cautionne pas du tout ce qui a été fait
ni le magazine mais on peut pas dire que
dakar acteurs on peut la faire pour
certains notamment pour charlie hebdo et
pour d'autres pas même si ça n'a même
jamais c'est pareil ça reste une
caricature sahara est une liberté
d'expression et je pense qu'on ouvrait
c'est le finir si on tolère ou six mois
à venir je te conseille de mal à ça mais
ça ne s'est pas du tout drôle c'est ça
le hockey m'intéresse nuls d'accord
c'est un récit fiction voilà mais ça
reste ça reste une fois la série k tueur
c'est une série de fiction et c'est une
brèche ouverte parce qu'on peut pas d'un
côté dire c'est mal et de douter dire
c'est bien donc je serais plutôt entre
les deux mais je veux dire non parce que
je trouve ça effectivement dangereux
qu'on s'attaque encore à une façon de
s'exprimer même sur la déplore même sur
la déteste il faut laisser les gens
s'exprimer moi delphine pourquoi venez
pas d'accord avec les décisions de
justice ben parce que les caricatures
effectivement c'est à base de dessins où
on veut faire réagir soit on veut faire
sourire ça on veut faire mettre les gens
en colère où on réfléchir ce qui est
vrai c'est que là ce dessin est
relativement bien c'est généralement les
caricatures il ya des grands nez des
grandes oreilles voilà on voit que c'est
un peu la récolte est caricatural stick
là c'est vrai que c'est un très beau
dessin les saints très réaliste donc je
comprends que ça puisse déranger
maintenant ça reste un dessin c'est
quand même très lourd comme comme quand
maman de guillaume moi je comprends
cette décision prouve qu'elle n'est pas
assez sévère au delà du dessin je trouve
pas de vue que c'est un beau dessin
saint des saints qui est ignoble et
c'est le même de l'article qui est
dégueulasse c'est une fiction donc ses
sorties de nulle part ils appellent ça
danièle obono au temps de l'esclavagé
et c'est quoi le propos en fait c'est
parce qu'une députée noire on imagine
autant les esclavages pour moi c'est oui
le degré zéro du journalisme c'est juste
racoleur c'est diffamatoire et c'est
honteux et ça doit être condamné les
racistes et les e mails ça faisait
partie en fait d'une série semblait
toute une série sur un tabac une semaine
il ya eu il ya eu daniel aux bonnes âmes
et je compte moi j'ai mis oui parce que
je comprends très bien que vous soyez
offensés et que donc que vous ayez gagné
en revanche c'est vrai que valeurs
actuelles là-dessus était a été très
maladroit voilà moi je condamne la
maladresse qu'ils ont eue parce que
c'était pas compréhensible leurs
intentions alors que sur les autres
articles c'était plus compréhensible
alors on va voir il ya quelques minutes
eric zemmour est invité chez valeurs
actuelles il a réagi à la condamnation
du magazine regarde ce qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui une justice politique qui
veut interdire la liberté de pensée la
liberté d'expression qui est elle-même
instrumentalisés par des associations
qui veulent imposer leur idéologie leur
doxa à travers des décisions de justice
nous avons fait des lois qui permettent
à ces associations
d'instrumentaliser la justice il faut
les débrancher c'est à dire qu'il faut
faire comme avant la loi pleven de 1972
ne pas leur donner ce droit ils vont
redonner ce soit uniquement là en
l'occurrence madame ans bono qui se
sentaient peut-être individuellement
diffamer qui est qui va à voter c'est ça
le principe et surtout il faut arrêter
de penser qu'il y à des incitations à la
haine etc c'est des concepts qui ne sont
pas juridique c'est des concepts qui
sont idéologiques donc il ya tout à
revoir là dessus
danièle obono commandant d'eric zemmour
qui dit que ce n'est pas de la liberté
d'expression est ce que pour vous ce ccc
c'est un atteinte est une atteinte à la
liberté d'expression
d'un personnage qui a été multi condamné
par la justice pour incitation à la
haine je crois que son propos n'est pas
très étonnant je voulais juste rappeler
que la liberté d'expression en france en
tout cas elle et elle est grande elle
est forte c'est une valeur et énormément
de gens se sont battus et sont morts
pour ça mais c'est aussi une liberté qui
est encadré c'est pas une loi de 1960
ans et la loi de 1881 encadre cette
liberté d'expression et le jugement de
la cour aujourd'hui a dit que ce n'était
pas du domaine de la liberté
d'expression etc je crois faire un
mauvais service à ce principe cette
valeur cette liberté que de l'utiliser
pour mener des attaques qui ne sont pas
elles simplement à ma personne parce que
le ministère public s'est saisie c'est à
dire le parquet la justice c'est la
république c la science est une attaque
qui à travers moi vise aussi des
millions de gens et des millions et des
millions de gens et donc non ce n'est
pas du domaine de la liberté
d'expression et s'est fourvoyé etc
instrumentalisé et s'est amoindrie re la
liberté d'expression qui est fondamental
en démocratie en république que de
l'utiliser pour mener des attaques aussi
ignoble alors geoffroy le jeune et qui
est venu pour réagir dans balances ton
poste et il paie des la mauvaise
compréhension proportion de l'article et
de la une regarde le dé s'en sort sur
les réseaux sociaux et vous connaissez
les réseaux sociaux comment ça
fonctionne et des gens ont interprété
notre intention est exactement l inverse
de ce qu elle était hystérique en gros
vous voulez dénoncer les horreurs de
l'esclavagé et casser le discours
indigéniste et vous vous retrouvez
accusé de célébrer l'esclavagé n'est pas
du tout notre cas évidemment bien au
contraire ensuite on a reconnu assez
vite une erreur parce que quand vous
n'êtes pas compris à ce point là ça veut
dire que vous n'avez pas été clairs et
que la manière dont vous avez fait les
choses n'a pas n'a pas n'a pas donné
satisfaction donc on a reconnu ça on a
dit évidemment que le but puisqu'on a vu
la réaction de danièle obono que le but
de l'opération n'était ni de la blesser
ni de l'humilier ni de de la salir ni de
lui faire de la peine et donc on l'a
présenté des excuses pour ce à titre
personnel voilà quand vous entendez les
arguments de geoffroy le jeune homme lui
dit quoi ce qui dit qu'on voulait être
le contraire il dit que c'était pour
dénoncer
merci pour ça qu'il a fait ça qui font
plus distants plus ce personnage donc ce
condamné par la justice pour racisme
explique que en fait c'est que je suis
idiote je n'ai pas compris les millions
de gens qui ont été choqués n'ont pas
compris et aujourd'hui la justice de la
république n'a pas compris parce qu'ils
sont trop subtil et intelligent etc en
fait et c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a été
plaidé lors du procès en fait c'était
presque un hommage quasiment j'aurais dû
le remercier de l'hommage qui m'étais
fait ça en ce qu'il a dit il a dit qu'au
contraire un temps comme des malades
voilà ce qu'il a dit qu'il avait été
maladroit mais il avait dit que il a dit
qu' il voulait se servir voilà 200 à
l'heure actuelle pour justement dénoncer
l'esclavagé on y croit je crois que je
crois que ce journal et son rédacteur en
chef qui a été condamné ainsi que
l'auteur est le directeur de publication
donc sont des repris de justice
désormais est un organe d'extrême droite
qui défend comme sait le faire l'extrême
droite avec racisme avec xénophobie
parce que c'est pas simplement parce que
je suis noir c'est parce que je suis né
en afrique il ya aussi cette ce propos
qui visent à dénier mon appartenance à
la nation républicaine parce que je suis
né en afrique et ça c'est un message qui
s'adresse pas simplement à moi mais à
toutes celles et ceux que vous venez ici
ou ailleurs et à qui on dénie
l'appartenance d'un asile c'est ça le
propos politique qui même lorsque volet
d'une manière qui est contre la loi qui
est une manière qui nécessitait d'être
sanctionné votre famille a été blessé
par ces dessins et parce ce récit ma
famille et mes amis et joints des
millions et des millions de personnes et
vous en dit quoi et je pense notamment
et j'aimerais y compris
je sais pas si on peut déduire dédier
cette victoire à un petit garçon qui
s'appelle emmanuel thomas qui m'a envoyé
un dessin de moi avec l'écharpé
tricolore en disant qu'il était fier de
moi parce qu'il avait vu ce dessin et
c'est un petit garçon qui je crois il a
dix ans qui va connaître et connaît déjà
en fait ce genre de propos de petites
moqueries des choses qu'on dit comme ça
c'est pour rigoler etc et je crois que
ce message s'adresse à lui en
particulier à tous à tous ses enfants
pour qu'ils sachent que dans leur pays
en république ce n'est pas justement de
la liberté ce n'est pas une blague c'est
un délit le racisme ce n'est pas une
opinion c'est un délit et donc voilà
pour ce petit garçon pour pour tous ceux
et celles qui m'ont exprimé leur soutien
et qui se sont vus à travers moi pour ma
famille bien sûr pour ma mère ma mère
qui n'a pas mis au monde et l'ex taulard
votre mairie ma mère elle a été elle a
été blessée par ces ma mère est décédée
à la mère est décédée et et c'est aussi
je venais là qui était qui a été insulté
pas sauvé la vie au monde elle a mis au
monde une femme qui aujourd'hui député
de la république elle m'a élevée pour
que je sois fier de lui il doit être
fier de vous et je crois oui je crois
qu'elle est fière que je sois député et
je crois qu'elle est fier qu'on ait
gagné dites-moi danièle obono vous avez
on a vu la réaction d'eric zemmour il ya
un instant vous avez regardé jean luc
mélenchon face à eric zemmour france a
soumis comme vous l'avez trouvé
magnifique jean luc mélenchon magnifique
voilà républicains là le seul a pour la
première fois devant des millions de
personnes faire barrage aux dangers que
représente monsieur monsieur zemmour et
je suis fier qu'ils soient avant
président groupe et j'espère être fiers
ce soit un jour président à leurs
clients